va démarrer ce coup de griffe et ce coup
de coeur par isabelle morini bosc à
briare un coup de griffe ma chérie
d'amour que celle ci mais fun leur agent
nous a aidé à signer en nous disant mais
alors avec le monde d'après vous allez
voir les gens tellement besoin de nature
on va être plus écolo on va plus
respecter la nature a pris le dessus sur
terre at c gepa cru un quart de seconde
j'espérais qu'on allait me détromper or
qu'est ce qu'on a vu hier partout des
immondices des saloperies partout bois
de vincennes bat boulogne canal de
l'ourcq canal saint-martin à longchamp
abbas a une incroyable que des gens qui
laissent leurs saloperies rachetant le
même pas des masses
et donc je me dis c'est vraiment fou
taches de graisse n'a pas on mérite pas
vraiment les espaces verts qu'on a est
tout aussi pour les amendes aussi cher
soit elle alors regardez justement on a
vu beaucoup d'incivilités partout dans
le pays
il ya david dickens qui a twitté des ans
ces jeunes du caire mais c'est pas
d'avis de dickens et s'il avait indiqué
qu' des congrès cuffies n'est qu'à nos
parcs jardins sont dans le même état
regardez vous avez une petite compil des
déchets de parc jarry des berges jonché
encore une fois ce matin vous le voyez
sur les images de courant tamara boeuf
jonché donc de déchets en tout genre de
canettes de bouteilles de bière de sacs
en plastique d'emballage carton et
détritus qui reste le matin parce qu'on
ne daigne même pas ramener son sac d'une
célèbre marque de grande distribution
que vous découvrez ici sur ces images
vous le voyez sur les images ya même des
masses car il y en a deux ici avec les
bouteilles en verre il a également une
bouteille de gel hydroalcoolique des
mouchoirs
voilà qui traînent un peu partout bah
c'est le coup de gueule d'isabelle
morini-bosc on la comprend il a ma
chérie tu as là à la raison il a un mois
mon coup de gueule c'est que j'aimerais
savoir où sont toutes les caméras
toutes les grandes villes sont toujours
en train de se vanter qu'ils ont mis des
centaines de caméras et ils s'en servent
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais au final on
a qu'a aussi pénaliser les personnes qui
sont filmés en train de jeter tous leurs
trucs par terre plein de caméras autour
des parcs autour du canal etc
on s'en servent qu'elle soit mal à pour
rien la bonne est mignon comment ces
gens ils n'ont pas le renom ya les flics
partout dans les rues on vit trois
voitures de flics parce qu'un mec jouer
les pythies route dans tout paris a
présenté les grandes villes ce qui est
assez terrible celui de voir en venir à
ce que tu racontes c'est-à-dire effet
car on est obligé au regard des rats ou
des policiers pour que les gens soient
justes civique qui prennent leurs
déchets après avoir piqué dans c'est
quoi qui le rend battu le ramène à la
maison et qui le met à la poubelle non
mais vraiment c'est ça c'est désespérant
on n'a pas arrêté de nous montrer
pendant tout le confinement des photos
de deux biches qui arrivé en ville ou
deux je sais pas quoi et là tout d'un
coup voilà oui serena réussir ici non
plus car les touristes une catastrophe
les touristes qui viennent surtout des
pays nordiques on est très propre on
respecte beaucoup l'environnement etc
quand il arrive en france y voit ça ils
sont effarés façon effarie